[Musique]
entre 1957 et 2013 l'union européenne
est passée de 6 à 28 membres face à
l'europe qui s'agrandit quelle réaction
côté français le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que tous les pays entrants ou
sont pas logés à la même enseigne
s'ils sont riches ça ne provoque
généralement pas de polémique
voyez plutôt lente et de la finlande de
la suède et de l'autriche
en 1995 le revenu de chacun d'entre nous
devraient augmenter d'environ 1%
parce que les nouveaux arrivants sont
riches plus riches que la moyenne des
douze autres pays leur arrivée devrait
aussi permettre des créations d'emplois
mais lorsqu'il faut accueillir des pays
plus fragiles ou potentiellement
concurrentes
nous devenons moins hospitaliers prenons
l'entrée de l'espagne et du portugal
nos vignerons s'en inquiètent dès 1979
personnellement je suis content surtout
que nous sommes très près à la chanter
atteint les portes avant par ailleurs
autres marchés elle est là la
législation n'est pas la même
les deux reproductions ne sont pas les
mêmes à l'hectare et quand l'adhésion
des deux pays se concrétise au milieu
des années 80 certains politiciens même
très à gauche s'y opposent fermement
nous nous disons nous sommes content
écoutez on a eu deux robes des six
l'europe des neuf l'europe des 10 et
plus ça va plus ça va mal alors pourquoi
faire d'europe des douze nos voisins
ibériques finiront par rentrer en 1986
dix huit ans plus tard c'est le big bang
européen
dix pays de l'est intègre l'union en
2004 les eurosceptiques montent au
créneau en dénonçant le dumping social
soit la mise en concurrence sur le
marché commun de travailleurs aux écarts
de salaires parfois gigantesques dans
ces pays là ils gagnent beaucoup moins
que nous les gens parce qu'on a fait
avec français faudra l étranger qu est
ce que vous recherchez les jeunes après
l'agriculteur espagnole des années 80
c'est le plombier polonais et le masson
tchèque qui font peur aux français dans
les années 2000 exemple à avallon où
justement une société tchèque rénove un
bâtiment de la ville
avant les portugais les espagnols
venaient pour travailler et s'installer
en france pour vivre en france alors que
là c'est une entreprise qui vient
travailler prendre un chantier et
repartir ça leur permet sûrement de
mieux vivre mais ça va certainement pas
nous arranger
aujourd'hui sept pays sont dans les
starting blocks pour rejoindre l'union
européenne
mais l'élargissement n'est pas vraiment
au coeur des débats prochaine adhésion
prévu la serbie et le monténégro pas
avant 2025
[Musique]